هذا ليس جديدا انهم بيهددوا ماهم يغتالوا
ما كل يوم في شهداء كل يوم في شهداء واحنا
في حركه حماس جزء من هذا الشعب ولذلك
نستشهد مثل شعبنا بستشهد ما احنا جزء منه
ونعتقد
بيوتنا ونلاحق ونطرد هذا هو الوضع الطبيعي
هذا هو الوضع الطبيعي لهذا الاحتلال مع
الاسف ولكن ايضا نحن نقاوم
ونطرد
نحن نقاتل واصحاب حق لان هو محتل ارضنا
ومعتد علينا وهو يهدد فينا وليس لدينا
خيارات يعني ما عندنا خيار انه لانه بيهدد
فينا بالقتل احنا بدنا نستسلم ونتوقف عن
المقاومه ما عندنا
ونحنا بكل صدق وبكل
مسؤوليه وشفافيه مثل ما بيستشهدوا ابناء
شعبنا واصغر شهيد من ابناء شعبنا تاج على
رؤؤسنا واكرم منا لانه سبقنا بالشهاده نحن
كمان على نفس الدرب احنا كل قياده حركه
حماس ومؤسسيها استشهد من الشيخ احمد ياسين
واسحب في غزه والضفه كلهم استشهدوا احنا
اصحاب حق واحنا
صادقين وعلامه الصدق علامه الصدق والسير
على هذا الضرب والاستعداد ان نمضي فيه حتى
النهايه والنهايه هي الشهاده والشهاده
بالنسبه لنا كرامه ومطلب
ولذلك لم تخيفنا لا التهديدات سابقا ولا
تنفيذ التهديدات ونفذوا تهديدات
واستشهدوا قيادات الحركه ومؤسسيها
وكوادرها
ومجاهد